CEUs make videos about things that you
want in your life you wanted to eat
expensive food so you start doing that
now you just want to get Instagram
followers yeah that's a great plan my
name is Steven that's Annie the producer
of the shoot this next week I want to
try to become Instagram famous
instafamous instafamous also really yeah
or not I thought you would judge me more
I don't judge people who are doing that
that's how you make money that's true
it's also how you connect with people
promote projects and like causes you
care about I feel like my presence on
Instagram is a direct result of my
presence on YouTube mm-hmm but it's not
because of it's different when I ask you
what do you think my Instagram give me
the thoughts okay
even you don't post at all there's a lot
of photos of you sort of posed like
you're going to a high school dance what
I mean it looks like a regular again
lots of smiles it seemed like a happy
boy I honestly wonder if you should just
be outside more I think half the appeal
of these instafamous people is
understanding their lifestyle travel I
would tell you to go to incredible
locations and I would tell you to make a
ton of famous friends I can find out
what kind of profile you want to have
and I think of the day it's not that big
a deal go out in the world be a real
person I got a lot of conflicting advice
from my co-workers so I decided to ask
Jen and Stephanie to season instagramers
for help I brought you guys in because I
need help with my Instagram it's gonna
sound really shallow but I just want to
be Instagram famous it's like oh that's
your hashtag goal I feel like you really
need to go into it with a different like
mindset and she thinks yeah yeah in this
day and age so many people are just
focused on the numbers and the numbers
describe your self-worth and I don't
think that's the way to go I think if
you just focus on creating the best
content that you choose and like the
your audience will start to trickle in
it can get really consuming just to
always just focus on the numbers we're
gonna assign you some homework the main
one is to post every day I think you can
do it get a good selfie with nice
lighting the solve it doesn't have to be
by yourself do it a selfie with a friend
will fill one of the photos with you if
you like we'll take a selfie together
you start that way okay yeah
just look through these photos so have a
bunch of photos from yesterday who know
all right I'm going to post this one
this one no wait no probably edit this
of a contrast
oh no okay you're playing around
vsco cam lay around with the filters
maybe if I use a filter I'll use like a
six that's my favorite one
no idea whatever this is what I'm
talking about
it's clean it's nice lots of light I
think emojis help to uh mode emojis I'm
one of those people you know in exams
who doesn't turn the paper and until the
very last again click ah it's out don't
try too hard cuz everyone knows it when
you're trying so hard oh that's deep
yeah on that note I just spent a half an
hour posting this photo since food is
such a big part of your life definitely
take a picture of your meal maybe like a
bird's eye view maybe the food and
showing the restaurant if it's pretty so
day two I need to sell my lifestyle so
I'm going to get some nice fancy
sushi yeah goes waiting for my food to
come out so that I can Ram it all
together but it probably is getting
gross look at this look at the sad ponzu
sauce just sitting there and like make
sure you put your location on put your
location in there no that's like stalker
101 you can post it after the fact
take the photo enjoy your meal if you
just post it and then any bounce so you
want the followers but you don't want
anyone follow you like you don't see the
irony now this isn't bad
oh my god this is awesome
these show no more tuna
hello
oh it looks terrible oh this one didn't
go Hawker
right now checking my stats and I can
show you guys this is day 0 to day 1 so
you can see I grew up rat on 600
followers because of Gen instead I got
around 300 followers from last post so
you definitely set up your editing time
well it's a lot easier to 1 in your face
isn't in it so one of the photos needs
to be an OOTD full-body shot of your
outfit
tagging the clothing alright so it's day
3 of I G life and I'm here with my
friend Sophia today who is a social
media wizards
sticking photos that I can't is so I
[Music]
have been getting followers at a lot
faster pace I normally do it really is
because of the consistency I got in like
more than 1,500 followers in the last
two days and that's way faster than
normal like usually I'm getting like a
couple hundred a week another photo that
you should get is a nice landscape you
need have to be in this yeah perfect
yeah thank you scenery scenic shots palm
trees are always good cacti so we're
here on the terrace of cityscape
skyscape thank you
the cool thing about trying Instagram is
that it also forces you to go out and do
cool new things right for outfit shots
this can't go wrong if you look tall and
elongated that's always the goal so what
we do for each other is you want to take
the photo from down low so if I'm taking
a photo of Jen I will even like crouch
down so that her legs look longer she
does anything for me so all the photos I
just took oh god oh my gosh it never
ends that's all today nope nope
yeah yeah candid so candid look at that
mustache I mean I went up there to get
some landscape shots got an OOTD it's
just getting really weird it feels I'm
spending way too much time thinking
about photos like I have to plan out
every single day what I'm gonna do today
that's fun and fancy and taking photos
in public is already awkward enough as
it is which so I don't do it and now I
feel like think about that this should
be fun for you it should not feel like
you're obligated to take photos of
anything ever if you're enjoying
yourself in the moment you don't have to
take a photo at all we definitely try
and like keep that mindset all the time
not gonna lie to me like 30 to 40
minutes to get a caption which ended up
just texting Zach Cornfeld for a caption
I'm gonna get ice cream
I'm gonna eat it plus my Instagram I
found that photos of me do better so
already this is what I want to hear
Annie can you take the photo for me
though because you're on camera okay
come on Instagram husband just like all
white background all right and then just
like ice cream in me and I'm saying I
don't know I don't know I'm doing okay
it's melting this is a disaster oh no oh
no turn around
notice best like a ticking time bomb
I'm licking the napkin right now it
looks really bad right napkins even like
the bottom Oh
[Laughter]
oh prior to this week started I had
fifty eight point nine thousand
followers which is a pretty good amount
now I have sixty one point five thousand
followers which is two thousand more
than before I'm actually really happy I
did this I feel like I'm very proud of
my Instagram now it is a better
representation of myself I like the
photos I put on there it took me about
numbers to realize that it's not all
about the numbers I think the best way
to go about Instagram is just being
yourself when I start to make Instagram
to something that I'm not that's when I
start to have problems I kind of felt
silly going into this like oh I'm just
gonna get some followers but there's
more to it than we see
[Music]